it was this beautiful woman just sort of
literally tripped and fell into my life
I spun into her life I know the fact
that she'll be really unbelievably good
at the job as well
before joining British royalty and
working with the Commonwealth Meghan
Markel had a very unglamorous first job
just like the rest of us during Prince
Harry and Meghan's Australian tour the
duchess of sussex spoke to students at
McArthur girls High in Sydney where she
revealed her first job included taking
out the trash - tell me about any of
this earlier the former suits actress
shared how that occupation shaped the
woman she is today
apparently the 37 year olds time at her
all-girls school in California made a
huge impact as well new idea reports
Megan really connected with the young
ladies and said they reminded her of her
younger self quote it makes me so
emotional you're doing really really
good work and I'm so happy that we're
here we give you our full support
soon Megan will be stepping into a new
role as a mom one step at a time and
will start found me earlier this month
Kensington Palace announced the couple
was expecting their first child together
it's a new chapter right according to
the palace megan has passed her 12-week
mark of pregnancy and is in good help no
word on the gender of the royal baby but
he or she is due in spring 2019 we're a
fantastic team we know real the Duke and
Duchess of Sussex seem to be ready to
tackle parenthood together it's been
cleared during the first week of Megan
and Harry's royal tour the couple is
great with kids
from pregnant Megan adorably embracing a
young child who gave her a hug and
bouquet of flowers - Harry meeting a
five year old boy who was intrigued by
the redhead Royals beard then the
mom-to-be even sported a handmade
necklace created by a dedicated young
leg
you
[Music]